good morning belief nation today's
message is what is your why over to you
Eric Thomas what's your why a and bounty
y'all nothing else you better start that
what's your why you know why I do what I
do when I do it so passionate cuz my
grandfather was a high school dropout my
father was a high school dropout I was a
high school dropout and we bout to break
the cycle I do what I do so my son won't
have to go through what I went through
when I was at the football game
my old do run with me I saw other kids
with a fire I said that'll never happen
to me I do what I do because my daughter
says she going to Hartford ain't even
about y'all I'm about to come here blaze
y'all why cuz I'm trying to get you all
the NFL
I ain't bout to miss this opportunity
this is the first NFL team I've ever
done in my life and I'm about to lick it
I'm about to give everything I got and I
will know if I won't get another gig it
won't having to do with the fact that I
didn't put everything on the field
what's your why why don't you wake up in
the morning why do you put on that
Jersey why do you go out and practice
why so do you think I think the most
incredible thing that any business owner
entrepreneur or inspiring person can do
is understanding what motivates you what
gets you up in the morning what keeps
you up late at night meaning not your
worry but what would you be willing to
work well through the night doing what
would you show up and do even if you
weren't paid for it and there's all
kinds of words for it there's passion
there's mission there's everything but
really it comes down to what fires you
what fuels you and when you find your
why when you find your greater purpose
when you find why it is you do what you
do and how it is you do it it unlocks
amazing things for any business or any
business person I totally agree for me I
love helping entrepreneurs your comments
fuel me when I was down on my youtube
channel and thinking ah should I keep
going I should I keep
they're not just waking up every day and
seeing your comments and seeing the love
you guys have for the channel and how
it's helping you when you guys saying
that it's changing your lives and
keeping you motivated that's fuel for me
to want to keep doing it keep doing
better keep improving the channel keep
adding more content and I think I like
to distinguish between little wise and
big wise the big wise I want to help a
billion entrepreneurs that's the big
vision that's the dream that's where
you're going and that's awesome can be
motivating sometimes it can be a little
demotivating too if you'd be like well
that's too big Who am I to hit that how
am I ever gonna reach that goal and so
the little why's are super important as
well and the little wiser the customer
feedback you get through the youtube
comments that you get just the little
daily reminders that hey what you're
doing is really important and is having
a positive impact on people and I think
remembering your big why's you little
eyes every day helps keep you motivated
and keep on producing amazing content so
the question today today is I'd like to
know what it is you would do even if you
weren't paid for it
a good question leave in the comments
below we're gonna join in the discussion
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso I didn't do the
whole thing but I worked at my job